at the risk of asking the totally wrong
person this question uh what advice
would you give to young people today in
high school and college about how to
have a successful career
or career they're they're proud of or
maybe have a life that they're proud of
oh
well first of all you Gotta Be You Gotta
want a life you're proud of not
everybody has any integrity and people
just a lot of people just want short
money I want to feel good look good
right now I want to do Molly boom I'll
feel good you know but you should
space it out he should it's almost like
saving money so you can use it later
nobody wants to save money what do they
say like 11 of America actually has
money saved a thousand dollars or some
[ __ ] it's wildly low
everybody wants it now now what do you
call immediate gratification I think the
key to happiness and satisfaction is
working for something
even if it's uh it's like a baby if you
could have a baby in five minutes if a
woman you gotta you jizz dinner and she
had a baby up five minutes boom newborn
healthy I think you'd be more likely to
throw it away
if you could make it that quick it's the
fact that you spent nine months back
breaking the labor the lactating The
Ripped placenta and the hymen or
whatever the [ __ ] that's what makes you
love it and I think it's the same with
comedy or or making money or whatever
look at these kids who who like child
stars they all become heroin addicts at
like 22 because they've just their
sensors are burned out they're pleasure
sensors you didn't have to earn it I
think earning it is a big part of life
and uh always try to do better try to do
more try to learn new things hey I'm
bored I life sucks I have to play the
piano then you Chooch but you you won't
do it because it takes effort and
failure and all that but that's the good
part yeah and I know it's hard to see so
I think that's uh that's a good good key
to life is work hard at something you
care about and then love the result the
hard work the journey is actually way
more important than just getting
something everybody wants to go on
Amazon I got a package then you feel
good for 10 seconds and all right let's
go on Amazon again and then you're just
it's just a dumb cycle of you being
disgusting and gluttonous so work for it
everybody wants to take steroids and
just poop I'm buff why'd you point at me
well I'm just not rushing or what well I
saw the The Icarus yeah but no I'm not
saying you're on roids I'm just you'd be
way bigger but uh I'm just saying you
know work for something and then I would
also young people eat [ __ ] early eat
[ __ ] early I know a guy who kind of got
canceled or whatever and he had an out
early but he tried to get by and he
tried to ride it and it all came
crumbling down but if he had eaten it
early like yeah I [ __ ] up I did that
whatever it was
he would have he would have just kind of
been been [ __ ] on for a month and then
it would have gone away but now it's his
whole identity and that sucks so eat
[ __ ] early and I know it's hard to see
what I mean early I'm in the present but
look ahead look back this time will pass
I mean look at high school high school
was the biggest thing in our lives oh my
God this exam Susie Q hates me the
football player beat me up I'll never
recover now you don't even think about
high school it's just a blip in your
dumb life you know and that's what this
is now this will just be a blip so
remember that and work towards something
and uh work hard and
care about the result if the result
isn't good try it again and failure is
not always bad failure we look at
failure is this end-all be-all my life's
over I failed but failure is really just
learning
so that's something so in summary eat
[ __ ] early and eat [ __ ] often yes all
right Mark Norman 8s that's the
escalated quickly all right